HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
IT'S E DALLAS
STARS.
PUCK FLIPPED TO THE LINE.
IN
DOWN ON KÄLLGREN.
TERAVAINEN'S SHOT IS
KÄ ANOTHER LOOK.
STAAL SENDS IT
OFFENSIVELY.DNESS IN EFFECT FOR.
THEY HAVE TO CLEAN UP DEFENSIVE
THEY GOT IN THE ZONE.
THEY ATTACKED THE NET.
PUT PUCKS TO THE NET.12-3.
21-9 THE SHOT NE.
4-FOOT PASSES, SUPPORTING THE
PUCK.
WAWANST KAMPF ALONG THE BOARDS
WITH LYUBUSHKIN.
COMES LOOSE.RIOD.
SECOND LINES BRENDAN SMITH.
LEAFS TO COME OVER THE BOARDS.
LEAD PASS OUT OF THE REACH OF O.
THEY ALL GOT INTO THEIR OF
THE LEAFS.
>> Chris: LEFT AT THE SIDE O O
CAROLINA.
GUYS SPRUNG
LOOSE.
>> Chris: GONE OVER 6 MINUTES M.
TAVAVA
THE PUCK GETS SHOT TO O THIRD.
TURNED OVER AT CENTRE.
STOPS IT RIGHT THERE.RE
BUNTS IT OVER TO KERFOOT.
AGAIN TARGET
ON KERFOOT COMING DOWN THE SLOT
MARNER TO LYUBUSHKIN UP AHEAD
FOFO CLIFFORD FROM HIS
SEASON LAST YEAR.
AND THEY'RE FOLLOWING UP HERE
.
AHO.
BACK TO CAGE BY
TROCHECK.
BOUNCING TO THE LINE.
AROUND.
HEHE